(upbeat music)
- In my expert medical opinion,
you gotta get a standing desk.
- Well you're an orthodontist,
so if I need braces
I'll ask for your expert medical opinion.
- Well then I'll recommend a back brace.
- No I don't want a back brace.
- Tough, it's either
prescription already out.
- Please.
(kisses)
- You're convincing.
- (laughs) I don't want it.
- Don't, don't.
- Sorry.
(moans)
I'll just read it.
Uh-oh.
- I know you're not going
to the office right now.
- I just have to grab a hard drive
and answer a few e-mails.
- If you keep working
100 hour weeks like this
you're gonna flame out.
Or throw out your back.
- On my way back into
the office as we speak
I'll get it done right away.
I seem to remember you
working all the time
when you had your residency.
- [Derek] Yeah but that
had a defined end time.
- [Anne] So does this, I
just gotta put my time,
pay my dues and not piss anyone off.
- [Derek] You work twice as
hard as anyone else there.
- [Anne] Yeah because I'm the only analyst
without an MBA I spend half my time
just fixing my own mistakes.
- [Derek] Stop putting yourself down,
you're the only one there with out an MBA
because you're the only
one who doesn't need one.
- You stay past midnight, take an Uber,
we don't want you falling
asleep behind the wheel, okay?
- Okay, I'm almost done.
(soft music)
Why are you throwing like this?
- It's late, I'm gonna go to bed.
- Okay.
- [Derek] Don't stay up too late working.
- [Anne] I'm almost done.
(drops)
(soft music)
- Anne?
Just wanted to shout out Anne's hard work,
in wrapping up the
Millstone Tires account.
(chuckles)
- [Friend] Well do you
want to marry him or not?
- In theory.
You know a few years from now
when my career is worked out
and I'm worth millions of dollars.
- So retirement?
Basically.
- I love him.
But.
- So what's the problem?
- We haven't even talked about it.
- Well people typically
don't talk about engagements,
it's a surprise.
- The ring is a surprise,
the marriage you talk about.
- Okay, yeah.
- I'll be home in two hours.
Three tops.
- Okay.
- I promise to be home before breakfast.
- Dinner will be in the fridge.
- Okay, thank you, I love you.
(clatters)
- Oh fuck.
Fuck.
You said you weren't gonna
be working 100 hour weeks
once Millstone was over.
Millstone is done, and it's one AM.
- This was a fluke okay, Paul was out sick
and I had to cover for him.
- It's bullshit.
I still barely see you and
when I do you're distracted
and a nervous wreck unless
you're at inbox zero.
You are seeking out work for no reason
and seeing you miserable
is making me miserable.
- Oh you liked it better
when I was sitting
at home unemployed?
When I was just spending
my time surfing LinkedIn
and stress cleaning the fridge,
is that the me that you like?
- Why does it have to be one or the other?
- Because half of the
reason I have this job
is my work ethic.
I'm not as smart as these people okay,
I have to work harder.
- You've got to stop shitting
on yourself all the time.
Why do you do that?
(exhales)
- You don't get it.
- No I don't, I wish I did but I don't.
I'm going to bed.
- Oh my daughter got it for me.
- (laughs) Spooky.
- Anyway I wanted to talk to you
about Marshall Spencer leaving.
You heard he's leaving right?
- Now I,
- Yeah well it means we're gonna have
an associate position open and depending
on how you handle Tanaka in
the next couple of weeks,
we just wanted to see
if you were interested.
- Oh, absolutely.
- [Boss] Great, I'll let HR know.
- What if we threw like a joint
Halloween/Anniversary party?
I would do everything okay,
I would make the invites,
I'd buy us couples costumes,
I'll do the decorations.
- You have to promise me
you're gonna cut back.
- Okay.
- No work emails.
- [Anne] No work emails
did you like your shoulder
kiss, did you like it?
- I didn't even feel it.
(kisses)
Nope didn't even feel it.
- You felt that, you felt it.
- I didn't feel it.
(mood music)
(upbeat music)
(types)
Hey there beautiful.
- Hi.
(jazzy music)
HI.
- [Guest] Oh my god the place looks great.
(chatter)
- We have drinks and candy
and also just a good time.
- Oh.
(shouts)
- With another round of antibiotics,
you might be ready for a replacement.
- Hey how's Tanaka?
- Oh, it's good.
Why did you hear anything?
- Uh,
no I was just making conversation.
- Oh cool.
I have to pee.
(pulsing music)
- Hey have you seen Anne anywhere?
- Uh no sorry man.
- Alright.
(whispers)
- Guys?
- Hey, Anne.
What the fuck are you doing in here?
- I just had to answer some emails.
- Okay well we just came in here to talk,
we'll talk outside.
- Whatever.
- Goodnight Anne.
- Come on John.
(chatter)
- Have you seen Anne?
- I think she was in the shed.
- Okay thanks.
Anne?
- No, come on.
Derek.
This is so stupid, just give it to me.
- Anne, it's not I said you,
- Just give it.
- Fuck.
Is it okay?
- [Anne] It's not okay.
- Anne.
(exhales)
- It won't turn on.
- Anne I'm sorry about
dropping your laptop.
But can we not let this
overshadow the fact
that I just found you working
in secret in the shed.
- Okay fine, I went to the
shed, I answered a couple emails
that would have taken me five minutes.
I have to hide everything from you.
- Fucking check with me.
- So you can make me feel guilty?
Do I need to check with
you now to do simple tasks?
- Anne that just shows me
that you don't actually care
about changing, you don't
think this is a problem.
You're just trying to get away with it.
- It's not a problem, I'm
cutting it back for you.
- You've got 50 friends outside
wondering where you are.
Is this really the kind
of person you want to be?
An email junky?
- Email junky?
I'm not outside doing crack okay,
you don't have to treat me
like an after school special.
- All I'm trying to do
is get you to own up.
- I did, I was working you caught me,
how long you gonna relish in this victory?
- Why would I relish in this?
Why, I'm not trying to
score points with you Anne,
I'm trying to help you.
- If you want to help me give
me space and let me do my job.
- You got it, okay, I'm
gonna give you space.
- I don't need you to swoop
in here with your engagement.
- What were you gonna say?
You found the ring?
- Mm-hmm.
- Why didn't you say anything?
- Found it six weeks ago.
We've never even talked
about getting married.
- I know.
Hey I'm,
I returned it two weeks ago.
- What?
Why would you do that?
- Because I didn't think you'd say yes.
And
I also didn't know if I
wanted you to anymore.
- Then why are we having
a Halloween party?
- I was trying not to
have this conversation
so close to our anniversary.
- (laughs) Oh my god.
Such an idiot.
You've just been phoning
it in for a few weeks
and you think I'm the one who lies.
I need you to get out of here.
Please.
- Anne, outside of me,
you need to see somebody
about this okay?
Like a professional.
- Okay, thank you.
- 'Cause I've been trying and I can't.
- Okay, that's fine, please leave.
Get out Derek.
(cries)
Just a second.
- [Neighbor] Hi sorry, I live next door.
- [Anne] Can you give me a minute?
- [Neighbor] Yeah sorry to bother you,
we can hear your music.
- [Anne] Not right now okay?
- [Neighbor] Okay but could
you turn the music down?
- [Anne] Get out okay?
- Okay, yeah, yeah okay, I
have a big test tomorrow.
- [Anne] Get out!
- Okay.
(shuts door)
(soft music)
(types)
(sighs)
- Oh no.
Great.
(moans)
Fuck.
Help!
Anyone?